e
okay we're going to go ahead with HB
1646 the first bill on the hearing for
the education committee this morning uh
this is a bill relative to Charter
Public
Schools and the prime sponsor of this
bill is represent luno we got a card
that's
great
[Music]
that's already got that I've got it
already so I take one
for good morning Mr chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Dave luno um representing people of
Hopkinson Bo and folks all across our
great state I'm here to introduce House
Bill
1646 um it um when I um when I put the
bill in um it it was it was basically
designed
to add a um uh really a hard floor to uh
re what what I would say would be the
the most basic of standards for our
public charter schools that um that
those schools would be private
corporations Incorporated under the laws
of New Hampshire and shall operate in
fact the the existing language says
secular organization and I added
501c3 corporation uh everything else in
here is the same except uh except we did
add the word secular to one other arean
statute uh where it was um inadvertently
um uh absent and uh legislative Services
did uh did all the drafting on this but
um but I don't want to focus so much on
the on the current language and like I
said really really sort of minor changes
on this but but um shortly after uh
after I filed it and um as um as as the
um Bill text became uh public or or not
maybe not necessarily public but went to
departments for fiscal analysis and and
um and comments I did receive a call
from um from Ms Davis over at the
department of Ed saying that uh that she
has for the last um several months been
involved in conversations with the
Department of Justice relative to
minimum standards for um for Charter
School approval and um that uh they were
hoping to find a bill that could be used
could be
amended uh for the um the
recommendations that uh that they were
working on and I said well look um
Caitlyn I'd be be more than delighted
more than happy to work with you and the
department of Ed and the Department of
Justice on um on any sort of um
suggested changes you have on this and
and happy to use this as a vehicle for
that so um just um yesterday and this is
an email that I've just passed around
the room actually represent Cordell you
feel you know the the email actually
came to representative cordelli into me
so um so and and and I hope
representative cordelli has had a chance
to to give it a look see um that uh that
uh that Miss Davis would like to have
the opportunity to use uh 1646 as a
vehicle for um uh for standards in her
email she uses the word retain I believe
what what she means there cuz we don't
retain bills in the second year and
interim study doesn't e even further her
her you know their interest to make um
to make statutory changes I think she
means amend um in this that's certainly
what she indicated to me when we uh when
we spoke um earlier this winter uh on
this um I have not seen what uh what the
recommendations from the Department of
Ed or the department of Justice are when
it comes to minimum standards or revised
minimum standards for uh for Charter
School uh approval and uh and it may be
related to to some recent events that um
that that that um uh the Department of
Education is uh and Department of
Justice are working from uh but um but I
guess you know we're we're obviously you
know not executing bills today I don't
believe this is well it's certainly not
an early because we wrapped those up
yesterday so we've got some time I think
to um to to uh to address this and uh
would appreciate the committee's
Indulgence in um in working with the
Departments of education and Justice on
um on any necessary changes that uh that
they feel uh should be made to um uh uh
to the framework for Charter School
approval so with that I'm happy to take
any questions but but really I think I I
I think it would even make more sense to
save questions from when we hear more
from from uh doe and
doj uh I do have one question for you uh
just getting some clarification here
you're modifying the definition for
Charter Public School under Roman 4 and
B1 um and there if you went down to
Roman five in that same section of law
you see a definition for the charter
conversions school which is a charter
that is a result of a local board and
Community decision correct it could go
further sometime down the road in years
and that Charter
Public Charter conversion school could
become a Charter Public School correct
so in any way does this language right
here
impact the nature of a charter
conversion school I believe it does um
and a charter Charter conversion school
if if my memory service me is a is a is
a locally
chartered it's it's a local Charter
School designed by the school board
right not the State Board not the state
board and the funding comes to that
Charter conversion School the way it
does previously to the school board from
the state however there's different you
know 80% and all that within the
definition right right and and and and
um and the the the the direct grants
from the state are different from for
Charter conversions than they are for
state board approved um Charter Schools
my understanding is that this touches on
both of those because that was the um
that was the at the Crux of the
conversation that I had with legislative
Services during Drafting and um and and
that's why they spent the time to uh to
do the to do the drafting on this uh I
don't know to what extent the
Departments of education and Justice
would would see that the minimum
standards for Charter conversion schools
would be different than than um uh than
stateboard chartered uh uh Charter
Schools but clearly those are two very
different um uh organizations because
one of them uh reports up through the
locally elected School Board and has has
the
the and the that school board is
fiscally is is fiduciary acting as a
fiduciary responsible for that charter
school and obviously the taxpayers that
that support it where a um stateboard uh
Charter charter school does not have
that same line of of governance just
follow up to that I I'm just trying to
eliminate any possible conflict or
confusion here we're in the amendment on
line three in the bill it says Charter
Public School is a private Corporation
comma yeah then under five Roman five it
says the charter conversion School means
a public school is there any confusion
here resulting from the language where
one place we're saying a charter is a
public school is a private Corporation
but here you're you were saying that a
charter conversion school is a public
school I I don't think so and I don't
have the the law book in in front of me
but but Roman 4 I believe is is directed
to charter schools that are chartered by
the state board Roman 5 and it does
touch on Roman 5 down in section
three
and in section four in section three and
and in section
four and like I said that's where
legislative Services felt they needed to
uh uh make sure that there was
clarity thank you representa
cordelli uh thank you um thank you
representative um yeah I I did receive
that letter and um I have talked with uh
Miss Davis uh several times um uh in the
past month or so um about uh the issue
and uh they have been working on a
really a
rewrite of the uh Charter School chapter
of law because it is
um has gotten a little bit confusing uh
between you know locally um chartered
schools and state chartered uh schools
um so they've been trying to do a
complete rewrite and um we did talk
about this as being a vehicle for that
um but uh last time um I talked with uh
them uh they were not
ready for um uh introduction of any
Amendment and it's my impression that um
they might not be ready um until next
year um so I think maybe that's what she
was addressing with the um retained
comment um in the letter um but uh I uh
um had sent her a note about getting
together on other topics um so I will
follow up with her to see if they have
any hope of um any um language being
ready by the time that we need to uh get
a bill out in March no I appreciate that
thank you very much representative
Cordell I'll follow up with m Davis um
on it uh on this as well um you know
obviously if they're thinking next year
it would just be submitted as a new bill
so you wouldn't have to interim study
retain or anything on on on this it
would be um not um U not used as a
vehicle at all but uh but if it um if if
if between um uh if if the Departments
of education and and and um and Justice
have have some immediate changes that
they feel need to be need to be put in
place particularly in light of you know
recent bankruptcies and and insolvencies
um uh at at se Coast SE Coast did
receive I think almost a million and a
half dollars in the um in the charter
startup Grant Charter and expansion
Grant so so at least from what I've read
in the newspaper there's allegations of
Fraud and financial misuse uh in that so
where that million a half dollars wound
up I I don't know and I think it may be
something that the Department of Justice
and the department of education do want
to get a better handle on obviously we
just passed a bill on the house floor
that would U that would open the door
for charter schools to participate in
the um School building aid program those
are also public monies and uh and should
School building Aid go to a charter that
then subsequently um becomes insolvent
uh we need to make sure we understand
what happened to that money we need to
understand um uh any obligations that
that the charter may have in terms of
liquidating assets or whatever assets
that do remain um um uh to to ACR to
what organizations benefit and um and
that uh and that we're not um you know
that we we don't have loopholes in there
for for fraud and Corruption I think
that's why the Department of Justice is
so interested in this Bill yes uh we
talked about disillusion earlier this
year here represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um of course I
don't have any Amendment so I'm just
going to look at the bill as is and
despite being a relatively short bill it
seems to me like it does a lot um and
without digging into a lot because we
don't get to do that right at this
minute I'd just like to look at one or
two things real quick especially uh
starting under uh Roman
4 um part of the change here is that the
organization must be incorpor ated under
the laws of New Hampshire that strikes
me as something we previously learned
about in a different Bill what we
learned was that it can potentially take
time a year perhaps longer for an
organization that might be organized out
of state to reorganize inst state so do
you know how many if any current
existing Charter Schools would be
disqualified under that change so thank
you for the question my understanding is
that current law does require our um our
Charters to be Incorporated in New
Hampshire it's that's different than
than what is in other states it just
doesn't happen to be in this section
it's somewhere else um uh so my my
understanding is that it would not
change uh uh any of our existing
Charters or the practices that existing
Charters use to uh to form in New
Hampshire the the F however and I and I
don't mean to jump ahead and imply
things in your question that that
weren't there that the requirement to be
a 501 C3 at the time of establishment
may may um may need to be looked at
again because there may be other uh
another IRS code that uh that a charter
gets established under uh uh Miss
Davis's U memo references that but also
says that um that there's at least I
think she she um says that there was
there's one um where their their current
IRS status uh of not being a 501c3 is
getting in their way of uh of receiving
um a u a bank note or something like
that so so I think there are some some
serious things that would need to be be
changed in the the bill as presented and
that's why you know waiting for um for U
some sort of feedback and guidance from
doj and doe I think would be uh would be
good
thank you yes it looks she said it could
be retained for a study committee and
whether that's changing amending it to
an actual study committee or just
keeping it for interim study because she
also says she wants to work on it
through this summer so that but rather
than just
leaving doe to work on it if we did it
as a group then we would have input as
well absolutely open to if if if wanted
to turn this into a study committee or
something like that I I I think that's a
perfectly good use for this bill further
questions represented
Miler thank you Mr chair just a point of
information one of the reasons why we
have successful charter schools in the
state is because of the
rigorous process that one goes through
to get a charter and it would seem to me
that this kind of a when you talk about
the
501c3 that this could be part of that
process and and and as I understand it
at least somebody told me at one point
in time it takes anywhere from once
somebody decides they want to move
forward with the charter it takes
anywhere from 18 months to 24 months to
get one started and that this process of
the IRS regulations Etc could be is
could be part it may even be part of the
process right now because of the
rigorous nature of obtaining a charter
in the state
are there any questions further
questions of the represent yes represent
Ry you thank you thanks for taking my
question and this is just technical um
in the part in line seven it says you're
appealing RSA B3 yes Roman numeral 3A is
repealed it's already repealed in the
statutes and then reenacted and I'm just
wondering how you do that I this is
where leg of services came in on that
and I I noticed that as well thank you
are there further questions for
represent luno not see thank you very
much great thank you very much do we
have anybody else here today that would
like to speak to this particular
Bill not seeing thank you very
much and so we have no further cards so
we're going to close the hearing
for
1646 and the next bill comes up at
10:45
e
we're ready to go ahead with the next
bill it is
10:45 by the clock in this time zone uh
HB 1087 is what we're looking at this is
a bill established in a commission to
study information literacy and media
literacy instruction public schools and
I welcome represent Paige
thank you Mr
chairman nice to see you all
again all right in in
2016 Stanford University's history
education group conducted a study on
youth media literacy skills in the
United
States this was their headline
conclusion young people's ability to
reason about information on the internet
can be summed up in one word bleak
in a more recent study of 100,000
students conducted by the nonprofit news
literacy project approximately four in
10 students could not recognize that a
meme about genetically modified
organisms did not contain strong
evidence for an accompanying false claim
about their
safety in study after study we're
finding that our students are not
adequately equipped for navigating
information in our 21st century world
so now for the good
news in the years since the Stanford
study was first
published more and more states have
risen to the challenge of closing this
media literacy skills
Gap 20 states have now passed
legislation focused on improving student
skills in this area giving New Hampshire
abundant and varied models to consider
evaluate learn learn from and adapt to
our local
needs New Hampshire can and should add
our name to the list of states that are
committed to equipping our students with
the necessary skills to navigate today's
complex media landscape responsibly and
critically which is why I'm here today
introducing HB
1087 students media and information
literacy abilities are not only ESS
ential Workforce skills they're also
foundational to their duties as
responsible citizens and critical
factors in their health and
well-being the nationaly of science
engineering and Medicine uh just last
year in December recommended in their
report on social media and Adolescent
Health that media literacy education
currently suffers from scarce funding
uneven content poorly qualified
instructors and a lack of reference
standard all four of these issues should
be
addressed it goes on further to note
that teachers are important ambassadors
in educating and continually mentoring
young people on how to address and
remain aware of new technological Trends
and as such need to be educated
themselves initially and on an ongoing
basis on effective ways to teach media
literacy so in other words it's not just
the students it's also ensuring that our
educators are are equipped to provide uh
this
instruction last year the US surgeon
general's advisory on social media and
youth mental health also explicitly
recommended that policy makers support
the development implementation and
evaluation of digital and media literacy
curricula in schools and within academic
standards they continue digital and
media literacy provides children and
Educators with digital skills to
strengthen digital resilience or the
ability to recognize manage and recover
from online risks such as cyber bullying
online harassment and abuse and
excessive social media
use so more good news New Hampshire's
taking a first step here so in response
to the surgeon general's findings last
year our governor issued an executive
order directing a Statewide response to
the impact of social media on children
in New Hampshire and this was an
absolutely critical First Step which I
applaud and in seeking to create this
commission
today we're aiming to build upon that
foundation with additional research that
can light the path to improving student
learning outcomes in this
area the proposed duties of this
commission Encompass a comprehensive
review and evaluation of media literacy
instruction in our schools specifically
the commission will review our standards
assess the availability of resources and
training for educators examine best
practices for integrating in information
media literacy instruction across
different subjects and grade levels
identify the challenges and barriers to
effective instruction evaluate the state
of our school library programs here in
the granite state analyze those efforts
that these 20 other states have taken
and ultimately develop recommendations
for legislative
action so while some states like
California New Jersey have passed very
ambitious and comprehensive legislation
in this area what is proposed today is
just a modest first step and a go slow
approach so we can figure out what will
work for us here in New Hampshire it
follows in the footsteps of other states
including Washington and Connecticut
that began this process in the same way
tackling this issue first with a
commitment to deep study and exploration
which frankly is what information
literacy is all about taking our time
making sure we do it right doing our
research so uh before I close I'd like
to direct your attention um to some of
the testimony submitted online which I
hope you'll re review in full but I just
want to pull out a couple quick quotes
from some of the organizations
supporting this Commission
uh in their testimony in support of the
bill the New Hampshire school library
media Association notes school
librarians have been Central to
Preparing media literate citizens for
decades promoting the kind of critical
thinking necessary to locate evaluate
and effectively use information we
support New Hampshire's efforts toward
making information and media literacy
accessible for students across the
state and then Aaron mcneel CEO and
founder of the advocacy group media
literacy now WR
people across the country are becoming
alarmed at the way children are targeted
by media messages especially in social
media manipulative messages and
information of all kinds created by
individuals governments and other groups
represent a great challenge protecting
our citizens from manipulation and
exploitation must include media literacy
education for children AI generated
information and messages are adding to
the challenge and the urgy
media literacy education is also key to
our Innovation and information economy
we need a population empowered to
participate to engage creatively and to
make decisions for themselves their
families their employers and as Citizens
media literacy is an issue on which we
have seen bipartisan agreement across
the
country so in closing I along with these
other organizations urge you to support
this bill for the benefit of our kids
and for the future of the Granite State
and I'd be happy to take your questions
thank you very much uh are there any
questions representative cordelli thank
you uh thank you representative paig um
and I I think I would agree with you on
a number of points including the fact
that there are groups targeting our
youth um and uh I maybe you can correct
me if I'm wrong but I I think that there
is a a lawsuit that has been filed
against um Facebook and a couple of
other social media
um sites and uh in terms of affecting
the mental health of students how does
it how might that play into this
commission's work if at
all sure um thank you for the question
I'm not I'm not certain of the specifics
of that lawsuit so I don't feel like I
can speak to that that specifically um
but I would certainly
say regardless of the outcome of that
suit what I would hope this commission
would explore is how
to ensure that children are equipped
when they receive these problematic
messages to be able to decode them to
understand what the underlying motives
of the messenger are and to be able to
you know be be more informed as they're
as they're trying to make their choices
in response to those messages thank you
uh represent Miler thank you Mr chairman
thank you for being here representing
Paige you obviously have't interest in
this topic could you for the committee
outline your professional background as
it relates to literacy books Etc sure
yeah so um my professional career has
actually been in publishing but I spent
about 10 years of that career developing
social studies curriculum materials so
that's where I began and then I moved on
to develop library and information
science materials for the next 10 years
of my career so I've been rooted in in
the education uh field for 20 years of
my career with a focus on social studies
and on libraries thank you further
questions from the
committee represent
beler thank you Mr chair and thank you
for uh for taking my question um So
within the bill within the proposed
commission it specifically um implicates
the uh the um organization youth
activism project I'm sorry not you uh
Media power youth yeah um so I've looked
at the um I've looked at them a little
bit to see what they're all about and
because they're obviously would be a
major part of this if they're on the on
the commission um they identify I I can
see three major core competencies to
what they're calling uh so uh digital
media
literacy um competency number one
focuses on Mental Health around
transformative social emotional learning
uh number two is identifying uh
disinformation through teaching children
what sources are or are not trustworthy
number three is digital activism which
they undertake through their partnership
with um Boston Children's Hospital and
they particularly highlight their lgbtq
plus advocacy with Boston Children's
Hospital so my question based on what
I've I've just seen here and what I've
just said is in a divided culture how is
this going to help as opposed to harm
the division that is already existing
about what is going on in public schools
sure thank you for the question
representative I'd say a few things one
is this is one member of a commission um
number two is I don't think that those
are there are a lot of different
information literacy models out there
that three-prong model you've just
described as one organization's approach
although there's continuity with many
other
models um the executive director of that
organization is here and might be better
um better position to answer some of
those questions more
directly um
I would also
um uh I I think that's I think that's
all I had another point but already lost
it and if it occurs to me I'll bring it
back represent paig I do have one
question then represent Woodcock um
within our statutes
currently we have set that we want to
integrate logic and rhetoric into these
learning areas which we identify as
adequacy yep and yeah I'm not going to
tou so much on the rhetoric which is
written in in in oral communication but
on the on the other side in in the area
of logic we're talking about students
being able to understand cause and
effect being able to discern fact from
nonfiction uh and and get into good
strong thinking skills do you believe
it's best to integrate what you're
trying to do here and provide more
professional development for our
teachers to know how to integrate logic
into all these subject areas seeing that
the social media is in social studies
and within the five areas of social
studies and all the other subjects we
have thank you that is such a great
question um I would say first of all
that's a question that this commission
should explore I suspect what the
commission will find is much in line
with what you're saying which is that
these skills need to be embedded
throughout the K12 curriculum and
throughout all subject areas um I
certainly know of um some schools where
this is taught as sort of
in a specific unit of instruction but I
think that that oneandone approach is
probably not the the best approach and
that we really need this instruction
embedded throughout um and one of the
specific areas of
exploration um that this committee would
be this commission would be charged with
is that question of what professional
development our Educators need in order
to be able to teach our children these
skills effectively so that would be one
of the key questions we'd be
investigating thank you if I'm if I may
I recalled what I was going to how I was
going yes answer representative bel's
question I just wanted to um add
regarding Media power youth that they
are the only New Hampshire organization
specifically dedicated to working on
this issue and they have also been
tapped previously by the state of New
Hampshire for collaboration for example
when Governor suu issued this executive
order they were part of the team that
worked with with the state of New
Hampshire on on developing that
curriculum so they're already they have
been tapped in that way
before thank you very much are there
further questions representative dry oh
excuse me represent would no no you you
on deck go
ahead thank you CH morning repres page
to see you again um I'm looking at uh
the timeline yep ly uh a fast time line
so is it your anticipation then that if
this bill uh comes from here and goes to
the floor and is pass that this study
commission this commission will be doing
their work this summer in preparation
for November is that a reasonable time
frame I think I personally think it's
reasonable when I imagine sitting on
that commission not that I'm going to
necessarily be appointed to the
commission but um I think that I'm
flexible on that if this committee is
interested in the idea but wants to
discuss a different timeline I'm
certainly open to that I I think I think
it's excellent the fact that you're
trying to expedite it and that you
brought it forward and I appreciate that
thank you so muches thank you represent
dry thank you thanks for taking my
question I guess I'm feeling kind of
left out because if this is going to
talk about
um proposals for legislation about
instruction in New Hampshire schools uh
we're not on the list that gets the
commission
report well let's put you on there I'm
happy to do that yes put you on there by
name even if you would like represent Dr
yeah are there further questions for
represent paig yes represent cordial
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here and taking my question it's a
quick one actually um as I was busy
taking notes and all I heard a phrase
digital resilience I think you use could
you just explain what that means a
little bit more maybe I missed something
or sure yeah that's um that was from
that was a phrase that was used
specifically by the US Surgeon General
in their advisory report um
my I I can't say with certainty what the
US Surgeon General intended in using
that phrase but my my interpretation of
that would be um you know how
to um essentially how to move on from
hostility that we encounter on on social
media day-to-day how to be able to not
internalize that and preserve your
mental health in response to this kind
of conduct that we we probably all have
encountered on social media thank you
very much not seeing any of the hands uh
thank you very much and we'll welcome
our next speaker Pam Harland from Pou
State
University maybe help us out with a
little of this professional
development yes I hope
so good morning it's nice to see all of
your faces and I'm happy to be here my
name is pamart Marland and I am a
professor of education at Plymouth State
University I focus my work on preparing
school
librarians to do their work I'm here to
lend my support to the bill proposing
the establishment of this
commission as Educators we have a
profound responsibility to equip our
students with the skills they need to
thrive in this 21st century now more
than ever this includes fostering inform
media literacy
skills um I'd like to present three
reasons why investing in this area is
crucial for our state's future first
enhancing information and media literacy
instruction strengthens the very
Foundation of our democracy and promotes
Civic engagement in our increasingly
Digital World the ability to critically
evaluate sources know the difference
between a fishing attempt and a
legitimate email discern misinformation
including information generated by
artificial intelligence and engage with
diverse viewpoints is Paramount for
informed
citizenship by instilling these skills
in our students we are nurturing the
next generation of active and informed
participants in our Democratic
process second improved information
literacy directly correlates with
economic competitiveness and Workforce
preparedness and let me know if you'd
like to see all the evidence that
supports this claim I have a lot of
references employers across Industries
are seeking individuals who can navigate
the vast area of information available
online make informed decisions and
effectively communicate their ideas
using a variety of digital information
tools by prioritizing information
literacy education we're ensuring that
our students are equipped to succeed in
this global economy and bolster New
Hampshire's economic
Prosperity lastly investing in
information literacy is an essential
step in protecting against the harmful
effects of misinformation and
polarization in our society in a time
where misinformation can spread rapidly
through social media artificial
intelligence and online platforms
teaching our students how to critically
evaluate information and recognized bias
is an imperative for fostering a more
informed and United Community by
promoting information literacy in our
schools we're taking proactive measures
to safeguard the Integrity of public
discourse and uphold the values of
independent thinking that are Central to
our state's identity in closing I urge
you to consider the profound impact that
a commission dedicated to studying
information and media literacy could
have on the future of our state by
working together across party lines we
can ensure that all New Hampshire
students are equipped with the skills
they need to thrive in an increasingly
complex and interconnected world thank
you for your time and for your
commitment to the students of New
Hampshire thank you are there questions
from the committee yes representa
cordelli thank you uh thank you for
being here welcome thank you
um uh you and the previous speaker both
mentioned misinformation and
um fostering out misinformation um I
believe that there have been several um
government um
initiatives um to um have um bureaus
agencies possibly set up to identify
misinformation just wondering you your
thought on government involvement in
identifying
misinformation I I mean personally that
feels frightening to me that that could
possibly
be something controlled by the
government and could lead to more
political
division um yeah I feel like instilling
these critical thinking skills in our
students across the curriculum across
grade levels G or
12 if we can do that consistently in our
schools hopefully by the end of that
time our students come out and they're
able to think critically about the
information that they're receiving
they're able to decipher what's
misinformation what's biased
information thank you very much uh
representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my
question so I'm wondering if you could
comment about what you are seeing in
your Plymouth State
students um what the range of their
media literacy and critical thinking
skills are now as they present to you
yeah thank you for that question um so
to clarify I teach graduate classes so
most of the candidates in my program who
are my students are adults most of them
are teachers Educators right now and
they are very interested in this topic
which is bringing them into the library
media program at Plymouth State they
want to learn more so that they can
incorporate integrate this into their
curriculum so many people are becoming
certified library media specialists in
order to do this work um a lot of my
colleagues at Plymouth State teaching
undergrads especially are um concerned
because as the students as freshmen
arrive they have such a variety of
skills and it all depends on
what school they went to as to how
consistently they were taught these
media literacy information literacy
schools um skills and that doesn't seem
fair it doesn't seem fair so Plymouth
has definitely integrated this into the
Freshman experience so that freshmen are
being taught how to do this on their own
so that everybody's kind of on an equal
playing Ground as they arrive at
Plymouth State as
undergrads represent
beler
quick thank you that was helpful um
could you also just comment if you have
seen a difference in or your colleagues
teaching undergrad a difference in
students media literacy capabilities now
say versus 10 years
ago yeah I'm I'm just not
sure I'm not sure I haven't this is my
eighth year at Plymouth State and so I
wasn't there during those times so I
just can't answer that but I wish I
could represent beler thank you Mr chair
and thank you for your testimony I
wanted to clear up with what seems like
it might be to me a a conflicting piece
of information um you testified when
when you were asked about the government
setting up this identification of
disinformation you said it would be
scary and possibly dangerous but this is
referring to proposing legislation that
will affect public schools which are an
arm of government which would
necessitate that arm of government
deciding what is and is not
disinformation so can can you speak to
what that seems like a conflicting
information sure um this commission
would not be deciding which resources
were misinformation or
disinformation
or working to like name specific
publication
to trust and whatnot to trust it would
be
teaching teachers to teach
students how to do that themselves how
to figure out themselves how to evaluate
and vet an especially online information
source does that make sense does that
answer your
question yes it it least partway does if
I may just just to follow up on that so
because it does involve necessarily
teaching media literacy to students at
Public Schools it does involve some
degree of what is your first principles
and what is your sort of foundational
belief system when determining these
things so does that not get into an area
that's going to become
necessarily
political I don't think so I mean we
don't we're not political in our program
of teaching teachers you know we teach
media literacy classes to graduate
students we teach media literacy classes
to
undergrads and we're not political we
all come from different political
backgrounds and ideologies and there's
nothing political about it I mean people
have their own personal politics but
this is about teaching critical thinking
and how to do that work yourself rather
than telling them this is the right
answer or this is wrong you're welcome
thank you I do have a sort of a up on
one of the questions I asked earlier
over the last year or so we've had an
opportunity to work with the provos Nate
from bodage from from pumma State and
and and of course Don Burk your
president um and in looking at the issue
of how we integrate higher order
thinking skills into the teachers
repertoire as far as how to ask
questions about what they're reading so
they are starting to think on a higher
level and sometimes it takes a good 20
minut minutes to get to that level but
what are you doing right now we've asked
this when we were in the teacher
shortage committee asked the questions
what are the university and the college
systems doing I'm talking now of course
you're you're a Pou state is a wonderful
teacher prep program so is Keen and UNH
has a similar program what are you doing
Within These programs right now to
prepare these teachers now even in The
Graduate level those on the you know the
upend of the scale and who have been
around for a while how are you
integrating these higher order thinking
skills into their professional
development um so their professional
development if it involves taking
classes at Plymouth State University
then certainly we're working on that we
are we have embedded a lot of these
critical thinking skills into any
assessments that we do um um their
discussions are filled with these big
questions that really get our candidates
to think in complex and interconnected
ways that feels
important
um they're working together
collaboratively
to discern these different skills and to
understand how to um think critically
about these about some of these
topics
um yeah I'm not sure if I answered your
question so you're asking specifically
how we're teaching our graduate students
or you're asking me specifically how I'm
teaching my graduate students to think
critically that's what you're asking
yeah it's you know I was a school
administrator and I used to send a
number of teachers to work with Dr
ranuli down in Yukon dealing with gifted
education yeah and of course there you
have to get up to those levels do and
and so a lot of that instruction down in
Yukon was how to ask the
questions and I'm I'm just curious to
know whether we're doing that in the
three teacher prep programs we have in
this state and you're you're in one of
Plymouth State I am I am and so we're
definitely doing that in graduate level
we are teaching people inquiry skills
we're teaching them to ask these complex
questions to think deep ly about topics
we're not talking superficial you know
I'm not teaching uh future Librarians
the Dewey Decimal System right we're
teaching them some really well be
couldn't they know that too
right yeah it would but that's not the
instruction but like why are we using
the Dey Decimal System how does that
help people keep information organized
thank you very much thanks
representative McDonald thank you and Hi
how are you good uh please excuse me if
this was addressed already I was
testifying another committee but I'm
looking at the membership of this
commission and it is asking from the New
Hampshire school library media
Association someone from an urban school
and a rural school and I am unaware of
where these definitions are what would
be considered Urban and what is rural is
that defined somewhere else in statute
perhaps what yeah could David page come
up and answer this question
okay so I'd be very open to adding a
definition there I'm also open to
discussing the composition of the
commission with the members of this
committee if folks think that we need to
look at that um so if we need
definitions for rural and urban there
I'm fine with that I'll tell you the
underlying reason for doing that is in a
lot of dis this discussion began
trying to look toward What legislation
might be right for New Hampshire and
what we quickly um discovered as a lot
of us were talking through
this is that we have some real divides
in terms of what would be realistic for
different
districts based on uh you know we had I
talked with one school librarian who was
doing the most amazing work in her
District where she had you know
these amazing results you know she did
pre-assessments of the kids skills and
it was really shocking and did all this
incredible work and on the other end the
results are just incredible right in
this one district and it's something
that you know it makes you start
salivating because you're like oh we
need to scale this across you know this
is what we need but then you know you
have somebody in an elementary school
library on the same call in a different
District who raises her hand and says
that's all great for you I don't have a
computer in my library right so we have
these this really important need as
we're discussing what the right solution
might be for New Hampshire that we get
these perspectives from different grade
levels that we'll need to be figuring
out how we integrate this instruction in
the curriculum and also that rural urban
divide in the state so that's where that
comes from but I'm very open to
discussing with the committee if we want
to um either look at the composition
itself more closely and discuss what
might work or also if we need stronger
definitions there I appreciate and if I
may have a followup yes uh thank you
representative Paige regarding the
composition the next section spells out
the media power Youth and I'm always a
little bit hesitant to put an
organization name and statute so I guess
my question is why this organization was
picked as opposed to perhaps another
organization sure uh this came up
briefly earlier in response to question
from representative beler but it's the
only New Hampshire organization that
focuses on this specific area and that's
the reason if there were 20 of them then
I probably wouldn't name them um but
they are the organization the local
organization that is doing this work and
has worked on you know Governor's Sun's
prior initiative in this area and so
there's an established there's
continuity there thank you thank you
thank you now we have several more cards
here and we do have to get out to lunch
and we have the governor speak at 1:00
so thank you very much thank you and I'd
like to welcome Susan
Ballard good morning good
morning um my name is Susan D Ballard
and I'm a resident of Manchester I'm
grateful for the opportunity to speak to
you today about my Earnest support for
House Bill 1087 establishing a
commission to study information literacy
and media literacy instruction in public
schools I am a retired New Hampshire
school district director of library
media and technology and a past
president of the American Association of
school librarians most recently I was
part of a national project funded by The
Institute of Museum and Library Services
through the Laura Bush 21st century
librarian grant program I served as an
interviewer and spoke with school
administrators from across the country
in discussing the impact of school
librarians on student learning I can
assure you that this subject is top of
Mind among them like so many in New
Hampshire these School leaders are
worried that Learners are not developing
the foundational skills and competencies
needed to engage with and evaluate
information resources in an increasingly
complex and dynamic global
environment the overarching concern is
that many of our young people are unable
to distinguish fact from fiction do not
comprehend the difference between points
of view and opinion versus accepted
knowledge or recognize misinformation
disinformation and in the worst case
scenario Mal information designed to
harm them as well as impact societal
interests this all represents a
compelling imperative to ensure that we
prepare students for lifelong learning
by equipping them with the ability to
understand the research process and to
recognize when there is a need for
information problem solving and then to
locate assess and use information and
resources ethically I'm confident that
the establishment of this commission
will help to identify strategies that
will pay dividends for our learning
communities and contribute to ensuring
that our students are not only
information and media literate but also
productive citizens and involved and
informed participants in the
preservation of democracy I urge you to
move forward with creating the
commission and I thank you for your time
and your thoughtful consideration of
this Bill thank you very much are there
questions from the committee represent
belard thank you and thank you for being
here I just had I had one question
because I'm not L myself 100% clear on
the distinction you brought up between
what represents a opinion versus
accepted knowledge so could you provide
that distinction for me what what is
meant um I would identify accepted
knowledge as as um things like we know
that the Earth revolves on an annual
cycle um that's accepted knowledge
versus someone who says no we're
standing still
um people are entitled to their opinion
but you're years of of research science
um
investigation have provided us with an
accepted base of knowledge that I think
most people would um would uh concur
thank you does that make sense thank you
very much further questions from the
committee thank you thank you do you
have a copy of your I do could you
please submit that we'll have put it
right into the record anybody else had
written communication to we want to put
that into the record as well yes that if
you could just hand it to represent Bel
at the end there and we'll put that into
the record that's very important I'd
like to invite Heather
iner is that i n y or
G okay thank you very
much welcome hello uh just check the mic
it works um hello chairman and members
of the education committee thank you for
um giving me the opportunity to share my
thoughts my name is Heather inyard I am
the a New Hampshire parent and the
leader of a nonprofit organization that
teaches media literacy skills Media
power youth every day I meet young
people who feel trapped in media and
Tech ecosystem that simultaneously
promises access to opportunity and at
the same time threatens their safety and
wellbeing we owe it to the children of
New Hampshire to teach them the skills
they need to navigate these tools and
prepare them for life after graduation
my comments today reflect my discussions
with our youth Advisory Board local
Educators and the researchers we've
worked with to develop our media
education programs much of the
information children encounter each day
is not from a book information is coming
from students from all directions in a
variety of formats for example they are
learning about space exploration on a
NASA live stream and getting homework
help from peers on YouTube they are
learning about history through virtual
reality experiences and reading the news
on Tik Tok if we value resourcefulness
and curiosity in learning we need to
prepare our students for these journeys
of Discovery with the skills they to
assess what they
find the information most students are
interacting with is much more complex
than just the written word the texts our
youth are confronted with feature
movement images and sound woven together
media and information literacy teaches
the critical thinking skills that enable
students to understand how each of these
individual elements contribute to a
message and to consider the source of
the information when deciding what is
and is not credible media literacy is
not about telling students what to think
it is about helping them to build a
toolkit of the literacy skills they need
to read the complex information they
encounter every
day it teaches students to ask
appropriate questions of their Heroes I
might love Tom Brady but should I follow
his advice about investing in crypto we
all saw how that turned
out the rapid development and
integration of artificial intelligence
into our communication tools and Data
Systems makes it even more important
that we teach our kids how to engage
with information these Technologies make
it cheap and easy for almost anyone to
create fake information including photos
conversational speech and even someone's
voice and likeness I fully support this
bill HP n87 to create a commission to
study information and media literacy
instruction in public schools media
literacy is by its nature
interdisciplinary and is often embedded
in other subjects including stem health
and language arts the benefit of this
commission is that we'll bring together
a variety of perspectives and help us
learn from others it will help us
understand what education efforts are
already happening in New Hampshire and
build on them by uncovering best
practices and teaching um media and
information literacy that can be shared
across Community as representative page
noted 20 states are already implementing
media literacy initiatives in education
and if we don't consider this issue we
risk leaving New Hampshire's youth
behind
thank you and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much we enjoy
your Tom Brady comment the six time
Super Bowl
champions um are there any questions
from the committee rep s belshire thank
you Mr chair I think you would be better
to answer this than rep page um because
you this is your organization so I've
perued the website a little bit um and
I've it really identifies heavily a
number of different pages on advocacy
and activism and digital activism uh I
know one particular page talks about
lgbtq plus advocacy your association
with Boston Children's Hospital but it's
not just your organization just I mean
even the plth State website specifically
identifies social change to be one of
the goals of this program so can you
speak a little bit about how and why we
would go about training students to be
social
activists um so we have several
different types of programming some of
it is in schools in terms of teaching um
critical thinking and that's corre ulum
but we also work in part with other
types of organizations after school or
youth leadership groups that are not
necessarily in schools um so I just want
to clarify that um element when we talk
about um being active in issues that we
care about there is in um education
project based learning and the theory of
active involvement and so when students
are actively working on a project or
creating something and they have to make
creative decisions about what
information to include and not include
that's when the real learning happens
and so when we talk about these projects
it's often a particular topic maybe
selected by an organization or selected
by a group of students on something that
they want to learn more about when we
explore and we act as coaches for them
to engage in necessarily in that topic
so um to help
them um Talk about issues in a way that
brings people together and to be
thinking through things like my audience
how am I building support for ideas
those types of skills but it's that's a
subset of what we do usually at the
request of a specific organization or
individuals thank you very much
represent McDonald thank you Mr chair
and thank you for being here as well as
for what you have been doing across the
state my question is somewhat along the
same lines what I opposed previously
about spelling out Media power youth in
statute do you have any suggestions on
possible amending language on how you
could describe your organization without
stating the name to leave it open-ended
for future organizations that may arise
um I I think we we we it for an
organization that would have expertise
in media literacy um and that works um
specifically with uh young people those
would be ingredients that I think are um
would be important in any um
organization uh Media power youth was
actually formed as part of a community
health clinic and so we always look at
health and well-being as part of how we
approach our work um so I think that's
something that I would need to think a
little bit more about how exactly to
describe it um but we have um worked
with many state agencies over the last
20 plus years on initiatives and um are
looking forward to help in any way that
we can thank you thank you very much
further questions from the committee not
see any more hands thank you very much
for coming today and we have no more
pink cards on this one so we're going to
close the hearing on
1087 and open up the hearing on our next
bill which is
1418 relative to the use of Education
Freedom account funds to purchase school
uniforms and I'm going
to
is represent Damon are you a member a
sponsor this
bill so he asked you to do it okay
that'd be fine we'll have represent
Damon introduce it then is that the same
letter that you had right there
yes good morning everyone for the record
representative hope Damon Sullivan
District
um I am here stepping in for
representative Horan who was not able to
be here to introduce his bill uh this is
House Bill 1418 relative to the use of
Education Freedom account funds to
purchase school
uniforms uh and the bill analysis it the
bill prohibits the use of EFA funds to
purchase school
uniforms and I will efficiently read
through representative Horgan's
remarks um hb1 1418 deletes one line
from RS a 194
F2 colon Roman numeral Tu bullet point H
which specifies school uniforms as one
of the items which can be bought with
so-called EFA vouchers the main
rationale behind this bill is that it is
unfair to use taxpayer funds to
subsidize school uniforms when other
school related clothing expenses are
excluded from the EFA program every
school has a dress code of some sort but
when it comes to meeting the
requirements of those dress codes
families are on their own unless they
send their children to a very specific
specific type of school that would be
religious schools such as Catholic
parochial schools and christiany as well
as non-religious private schools a
secondary rationale that is that it is
unfair to exclude non-fa families from
this benefit there are a few chartered
public schools which require uniforms
although to the best of my knowledge no
regular public schools here in New
Hampshire require them as I've already
said all schools have a dress code of
some sort neither the EFA program or the
educ tax credit program provide any
assistance of any sort to public school
families it is hard to tell exactly how
much taxpayer money is being spent on
school uniforms but it is a significant
though admittedly not huge amount
halfway through the 2223 school year
education commissioner Frank adbl
compiled a rather vague report entitled
quote EFA spending by spending category
unquote a spending category called
simply school uniforms amounted to to
$3,059 spread over 282 students that
amounts to 66% of the overall
4,568
620 which was spent over that applicable
time period apparently the second half
of calendar year
22 this divides out to $106 per covered
student there were four other spending
categories whose titles included the
phrase school uniforms alongside other
things a second report covering the same
period entitled EFA by vendor shows that
the high-end online clothing store L end
received $
7,459 in EFA spending spread over 48
students that averages out to
$155.4 cents per covered student judging
by what I have seen on lanen website
their school uniform offerings are
comparable to their regular merchandise
I.E high quality but not
inexpensive the overall cost of the EFA
Voucher Program has continually
increased by a massive amount since 202
2022 with no end in sight and presumably
school uniform spending has gone up
along with all the other spending
categories I'm not necessarily opposed
to school uniforms per se but I do not
think they should be subsidized by the
taxpayers I know there are many families
who can't afford uniforms but their
needs can be met by private charity or
by the schools themselves one way to
meet those needs would be to privately
subsidize purchases and gifts of new or
used uniforms and another way would be
to set up hy- down programs for children
who lack older
siblings and that is uh representative
Horgan's testimony on his bill hp1 1418
thank
you well see you're not taking question
because you're not represented Horgan
correct so with that we're going I have
no other pink cards on this so we're
going to close the hearing
down all right
do we have any kind of a CO prior to
this yeah 12 o00 oh the Democrats too
God I didn't bring my
Lun yeah spent a lot of money at L
that's for sure on those
un where is it in rep yeah I'm going to
just go out and get a sandwi and yeah
right
yeah
yeah oh yeah get them there
quity because it is a little more
expensive